[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre et discuter et réfléchir sur
les grands enjeux qui touchent nos
vielles qui font l'actualité
le thème de ce soir le téléthon en
période de crise sanitaire
plus de 87 millions d'euros c'est le
bilan du téléthon 2010 9
un montant que les bénévoles les
organisateurs aimeraient voir battu pour
lacan la 34e édition
mais l'épidémie de kobe 19 risque de
remettre de rebattre les cartes pourtant
les manifestations vont se tenir et on
va voir ce qu'il en est dans les
yvelines avec nos trois invités alors en
plateau tout d'abord daniel basant
coordinateur du secteur est d y viennent
pour le téléthon bonsoir bonsoir et vous
en avez maintenant l'habitude
nous avons des invités en visio pour des
raisons sanitaires
sandrine mieux regarder là vous êtes
adjointe au maire de la commune de
château fort et co organisatrice du
téléthon bonsoir bonsoir oui tout à fait
et michel crétins êtes adjoint au maire
délégué aux sports de la commune de
montigny le bretonneux pour soir à vous
aussi
bonsoir alors s'adapter au couvre feu
puis au confinement les dernières
semaines ont dû être plutôt studieuses
pour les bénévoles organisateurs du
téléthon dans les yvelines
daniel basant vous êtes le coordinateur
pour le secteur est est ce que déjà le
marathon annuel va pouvoir se tenir dans
votre secteur cette année
mais oui je crois que rien de juin des
bonnes perspectives qui sont en cours ce
que
comme je le disais un bon émission
l'année dernière on avait fait 80 contre
1 cette année nous en sommes 1,74 dans
que quinze nouveaux donc je peux dire
que c'est une très belle perf et cie qui
s'annonce et j'espère commun que la
collecte soit en hauteur de de ses 74
comprend qu'ils ont été signés pour le
moment là alors dont 74 malheureusement
vous ne verrez pas du tout de
manifestations sur le terrain parce que
les mesures sanitaires un oblique et on
tient vraiment que ça soit respectée
dans que tout cela en visuel et enfin
parler on va développer tout au long de
cette émission de ce qui va être mis en
place alors là on a parlé du secteur est
on va s'intéresser quelques secondes au
secteur ouest puisqu'on a posé quelques
questions à jean jacques de me dire
c'est le coordinateur du secteur ouest
on écoute
[Musique]
pour nous était une évidence l'on ne
peut absolument pas se permettre d'avoir
une année blanche
nous finançons à la fois de la recherche
à travers des appels d'offres
ces deux centres de recherche aux
courses jeunes chercheurs qui sont
financés par l'afm téléthon et donc à
l'agencé mais c'est aussi des
laboratoires que soutenons et qui ne
peuvent pas se permettre d'être une
année sans ressources
et puis on a aussi notre part de nos
ressources qui sont dédiées à
l'accompagnement des malades a beaucoup
de contacts avec nos bénévoles sur le
terrain avec l'ensemble des bénévoles
dont je rappelle qu'ils sont rouvre de
250000 chaque année à se mobiliser sur
le terrain on a proposé des choses qu
vide compatible puis confinement qu'on
patine concrètement sur le terrain ça va
se traduire par des drives the click and
collect comme ça on est bien à la page
et puis de la visibilité de l'affichage
[Musique]
je suis d'une nature positive et
optimiste je vais parler évidemment plus
de mai et ce point là le téléthon est un
événement de se définit comme monde à la
fois par son ampleur aussi par ses
résultats et nous avons de belles
victoires thérapeutique encore annoncés
cette année j'ai tout à bien suivre
cette édition 2001 parce que c'est une
manière de leur rendre compte aussi de
tout ce dont on est capable grâce à leur
mobilisation
vous l'aurez compris ne s'agissait pas
de jean-jacques de me dire le corps d'un
acteur du secteur ouest mais de nolwenn
le floch la directrice et directrice
collecte et mobilisation de l'événement
alors là maintenant on va écouter jean
jacques des mesures pour voir la
situation dans le secteur ouest au
niveau des contacts et des contrats
d'engagement qu'on doit signer avec
chacun de nos organisateurs
il sera plutôt aux trois quarts plein et
je trouve que c'est quand même déjà
assez extraordinaire que nos
organisateurs
dans ces conditions se mobilisent face
preuve d'imagination pour avoir
peut-être 70 contrats sur les 90 de l'an
dernier donc c'est pas si mal
alors on l'aura compris les gens se
mobilisent parce que la mobilisation est
encore nécessaire
michel creton c'est ce qui vous a motivé
vous à montigné de vous relancer ça fait
33 ans que vous faites le téléthon à
montigny-le-bretonneux
oui tout à fait découpez nous notre
préoccupation était de savoir
effectivement comment nous allions
continuer à assurer la continuation de
l'opération téléthon 2020 en tenu du
contexte actuel est en fait très vite
c'est apparu d'abord sous la pression
aussi des les associations je veux dire
la pression j'ai des demandes plus tôt
les associations sportives culturelles
et sociales de la ville qui sont très
mobilisés pour le pour le téléthon
généralement est donc cette année nous
avons effectivement réfléchit à un
téléthon et je vais faire sourire daniel
bazin puisque là dessus c'est un
téléthon qu'on appelait 2.0 non
puisqu'il va se passer effectivement
entièrement tient entièrement en vidéo
et en plus vous faites durer presque
plaisir on peut dire parce que vous
partez sur une quinzaine vos animations
vont durer jusqu'au 18 décembre
oui tout à fait vous savez le téléthon
c'était pour nous un week-end complet
donc du vendredi soir jusqu'au dimanche
matin est donc là cette année
comme on n'a pas la possibilité de le
faire en présentiel
pendant qu'on a décidé effectivement de
une formule qui va permettre sur quinze
jours d'avoir chaque jour un défi
différent là le principe je vous
l'expliqué très brièvement
il s'agit pour chaque association de
pouvoir proposer un défi ou un ou une
comment dire un challenge qui sera
regroupée au sein de chaque association
et le président de ces associations
décidera de quel est le challenge où le
défi qui est le plus intéressant et pour
pouvoir le proposer
et nous le proposerons au niveau du site
internet de la ville à travers des
réseaux sociaux
et chaque jour on pourra déterminer voir
un petit peu ce défi ce challenge est
chaque fois conclus par le message d'
appeler le 36 le 36 37 2 du téléthon
alors cette année le thème de l'édition
c'est trop fort les communes qui
contiennent le mot fort on est donc été
sollicité par l'afm dans les yvelines
ses châteaux forts qui a accepté de
relever le défi et c'est une première au
quasi première ce que le téléthon ne
sont organisés plus depuis 10 ans
sandrine un mur gadella vous n'avez pas
eu de craintes à vous lancer cette année
dans ce contexte si particulier
en fait on n'a pas craint pas d'aller
tous très envie de me faire coter
municipal et quand on a lancé le sondage
auprès de nos habitants on a eu quand
même pas mal de réponses positives on a
eu dix quinze personnes qui nous ont
répondu favorablement avec toutes les
idées et donc on sait dès qu'on de qu'on
devait se lancer et donc on a en fait
l'enseignement organisé une première
réunion physique avec ses bénévoles
chacun avait vraiment des idées déjà
bien réfléchi bien structuré qui est
crétin prêtes à être mises en oeuvre
assez rapidement le coup
vous souhaitez arrivait juste derrière
donc on a un petit peu revu à la fois
nos manières de nous organiser de
travailler ensemble et puis évidemment
certaines de nos activités
la réunion suivante confinement donc on
a effectivement revu à nos différentes
animations et on s'est vraiment on s'est
vraiment motivé pour se dire de toute
façon quoi qu'il advienne comme on est
on construit tout de zéro
eh ben on peut y aller sur des
animations numériques et donc on avait
certaines animations qui était qui était
prévu en physique et qu'on a basculé sur
des numériques
typiquement un flash mob avec des
danseurs de la commune et à leurs
professeurs dans une troupe semi
professionnel une exposition qui était
prévu au domaine de la jeunesse sur
château fort qui va être refaite en
virtuel donc avec un film vidéo qui
pourra diffuser auprès des habitants qui
s'abonneront des animations il y o'gara
technologie des choses comme ça qu'ils
vont nous permettre de proposer à nos
attentes en différentes activités
daniel fazan de voir des nouvelles
communes qui s'engagent ou même celles
qui sont là depuis le début
être encore motivés alors qu'on peut se
dire qu'on peut avoir l'esprit ailleurs
aussi les communes ont à gérer toute
cette épidémie oui oui oui c'est vrai
que mais bon on sait que les français
sont des très bons amateurs et ça fait
plaisir de voir mon unique est toujours
là chateaufort qui était parti quelques
les années bonsens euros noël
sandrine qui répond là le flambeau je
suis assez satisfait de ce qui se passe
sur les yvelines et en fait on va dire
sur l'ensemble des yvelines parce que je
vois que
suivent mon collègue jean jacques le
taux de contre 1 est très élevée aussi
donc je crois qu'on ne sera pas les
derniers au niveau du nombre de
contraintes dans les yvelines parce
qu'il ya quelques temps de ça on avait
parlé de 35% des contraintes qu'ils
étaient renouvelés et là nous on arrive
presque à la totalité on voit il a fallu
rivalisé d'imagination est-ce que entre
communes monsieur kreuth un madame mais
regardez là on échange on regarde ce que
font les voisins pour trouver des
petites idées pour se donner des outils
techniques aussi à chaque fois tu as we
m'écouter n'ont jusqu'à présent je
dirais qu'il le nombre de personnes qui
s'occupent du téléthon sur la commune
dont je dirais qu'on a toujours
effectivement venu du menu du de nos
associations suffisamment de l'idée
qu'on pouvoir pour pouvoir les battre
les mettre en oeuvre et qu'on ne pensait
pas forcément attaché à regarder ce qui
se passait tout autour puisqu'il ya déjà
un engagement qui était qui était quand
même assez extraordinaire
je dirais qu'on n'a jamais été à court
d'idées là dessus
madame eu regardez là aussi vous êtes
très active enfin la commune pardon est
très active sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est un moyen aussi de vérifier que les
gens seraient là et que les idées
fonctionne effectivement si un point
indispensable cependant le contexte
actuel parce que le nôtre craintes
étaient effectivement les gens se disent
que le téléthon n'aurait pas lieu dont
ils sont victimes en cet événement est
donc on a souhaité très tôt engagé de
vous une campagne de communication
d'accorder notre page facebook
spécifiquement pour cette l'ensemble des
animations qu'on publie régulièrement
donc on est évidemment soutenue par la
ligue effectivement il ya quelques élus
dans le comité d'animation qui
soutiennent et d'organiser différentes
animations et donc on a bâti un peu en
communication pour mettre en avant tous
nos donateurs successivement tous les
toutes les personnes qui vont donner de
temps en animant des ateliers dont les
bénéfices seront versés au téléthon les
gens qui donnent dès lors notre tombola
plus loin je ne vais pas ni dans les
animations résister
une tombola avec un certain nombre de
lots donnés par commerçants les
restaurants notre salon quoi tuer les
personnes qui ont des ateliers soins de
bien-être c'est ces gens qui ont donné
de leur temps pour des lots ou pour des
ateliers et donc progressivement en fait
les mettre en avant notre notre page de
communication spécifique des coûts et la
page de la ville relais dans encore
quand il ya une synthèse ou quand il ya
des événements un petit peu marquant
c'est d'information la discussion soit
la plus large possible et c'est
important effectivement que de cette
communication vous fait au travers de
nos animations et de des publications
qu'on peut le post et permettent aux
gens de se dire que le téléthon à dieu
qui peuvent donner dès maintenant sur
des 40 pages de collecte qu'on a mis en
place la sociale aux animations mais
aussi le moment venu le jour j les jours
j puisque il ya effectivement plusieurs
avec le 36 37 ou avec les pages de
connect qui effectivement de notre côté
resteront ouverts que si jusqu'au 20
décembre dans le cadre du budget des
activités qu'on a mise en place d'un
challenge pour répondre à votre question
tout à l'heure on a poussé un spear et
de ce qui vous fait ailleurs on a un
challenge 2 km cumulés sur la commune
qui peut mobiliser tout le temps qu'ils
soient à pied en vélo ou en course pour
le plus grand nombre de kilomètres et
donner régulièrement de l'argent on
regarde ces kilomètres parcourus et donc
ça peut durer jusqu'au 20 décembre et ça
s'agite raf à l'ensemble des banques
réparé par téléphone sur un titre en
tête les gens commencent bien justement
oui les dons au téléthon c'est ce qui
fait monter la cagnotte chaque année
lors nous chaque semaine on pose une
question à nos téléspectateurs et cette
semaine c'est avec l'annulation de
nombreuses manifestations caritatives
est ce que vous allez faire plus de dons
en ligne et les votants chez nous ont
répondu non à 76% d'année le bazin est
ce que c'est un résultat qui vous étonne
voir qui vous inquiète 2 ils vont
peut-être moins données en ligne donc
comme ya moins de manifestation qu'est
ce que ça pourrait amener je suis je
suis pas certain que
il y en a toujours qui vont pas donné
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'aller sur les
manifestations
mais je ne suis pas certain vraiment
qu'on soit on baisse ensemble 6e mais on
a beaucoup de manifestations qui sont
reportés en début d'année donc ce qui
laisse quand même un petit espoir commun
de pouvoir tenir le choc parce que bien
sûr on a besoin comme le disait michel
comme le disait sandrine en un besoin de
dedans donc appeler le 36 35 fait des
dons ou prêts dès des communes on a un
beau coup de communes qui participent
peu route et les temps donc n'hésitez
pas un fait des dons en fait à peine 36
on est là pour vous recevoir du sacré
temps j'imagine c'est pareil montigny
sur ces quinze jours ça va être toujours
de rappeler vous pouvez donner n'ya pas
de déplacements il ya moins de
convivialité mais il faut donner mais il
faut donner oui tout à fait et puis on a
aussi parmi des différentes associations
qui doivent qui vont intervenir hier par
exemple un tournoi de poker en ligne qui
est donc lui le poker toujours
l'habitude de participer à nous et à nos
à nos séances de téléthon en présentiel
hélas cette année donc va le faire en
ligne et docteur lui a lui-même récolte
déjà pas mal de pas mal de fonds on a
aussi par exemple pour la culture
une des spectacles etc un spectacle qui
va avoir lieu au mois de février
donc en espérant qu'il est mieux quand
même par rapport à ce qui se passe en ce
moment autour de nous et donc les les
organisateurs sont engagés à reverser
une partie des prix des places pour le
téléthon donc ira effectivement il y
aura l'engagement qui est le moment même
donc pendant la quinzaine mais il y aura
aussi à posteriori des déversements qui
pourront être qu'ils pourront être
important et qui viendront garnir la la
tirelire du téléthon et sandrine me
regardent et laissent qui a encore des
choses dans
les cartons ou vos animations sont
faites sont posées et on attend
d'arriver à ce week-end on n'a pas son
elles sont toutes identifiées
je ne veux pas du tout citer pascal a
effectivement un nombre important elles
ont toutes démarré un petit peu
finalement depuis une quinzaine de jours
puisqu'on a mis en place nos billets tri
où nos pages de collecte finalement
assez tôt pour que les gens puissent
progressivement prendre connaissance de
ce qu'on mettait à disposition puissent
réserver tranquillement leur biais cas
des animations comme le premier cours de
yoga qui ont déjà eu la semaine ont déjà
eu lieu la semaine dernière
et puis nous l'idée c'est effectivement
que les gens en allant s'inscrire à une
des activités voix il y à d'autres et
puis finalement pas retranscrit votre
autre animation qu'on propose le
kilomètre le cumul de kilomètres des
choses qui se fait qu'ils se font déjà
des dizaines de jours on a aussi mais
c'est vrai que je ne les ai pas cités il
ya l'association parents d'élèves de la
commune qui a souhaité cette année ils
font traditionnellement une vente de
sapins avec une livraison ces deux
mamans de la commune et les parents
finalement viennent chercher leurs
sapins chacun cette année ont ils se
sont d'abord dit on ne peut pas le faire
cette année
et finalement en faisant un petit peu en
questionnant cherchant d'autres
solutions on aura quand même les
livraisons de sapins à domicile chacun
recevra son son sapin devant chez lui et
le le bénéfice de cette vente va être
content être reversés intégralement au
téléthon
d'habitude ça va pour l'animation des
écoles mais cette année comme il n'y en
a pas eu
il n'y avait pas ce besoin là donc ils
ont choisi de maintenir cette vente est
de tout donner au profit du thé dépôt
donc nos animations sentiments ils s'en
foutent déjà en ligne et on n'a pas de
nouvelles identifiées mais effectivement
on avait déjà une liste assez
intéressante qu'on a vraiment construire
relativement tôt courant octobre
dès nos premières ayant été d'habitants
on était plein de plein d'idées puisque
effectivement c'était tout nouveau pour
nous comme vous l'avez vous est donc
plein d'envié de deux gardiens qui ont
lavé un défi à relever l'équipe du
téléthon est venu nous chercher en
polymère en nous disant trop fort vous
êtes obligés de faire quelque chose et
c'est comme ça qu'on a motivé notre
temps et on espère bien qu'à la fin le
résultat sera présent que je pense que
nous de total est déjà supérieur à ce
qu'on a traditionnellement sur la
commune donc monsieur gbagbo
et justement daniel vasella on l'a vu
c'est l'engagement de toutes ces
personnes mais il faut aussi noter
signalé que certaines communes tous les
frais qu'ils n'auront pas été engagés
sur des salles prêtées pour être reversé
à la ville de villes prouvent à faire un
don ça va compter aussi tout à fait donc
ça c'est une initiative des maires de
france donc de reverser un peu on va
dire il en arrive à lui est un petit peu
chiant que gym n'a pas ce que c'est
amener quand même des frais et donc il
ya des communes qui joue on va dire
jouent le jeu et qui reverse donc cet
homme
donc c'est pour ça que je suis assez on
me dit tu verras daniel y aura des
surprises et je l'espère est ce que je
voulais dire c'est que oui si vous
voulez pas faire de 36-37 fait un chèque
au nom de l' iphone et on est prêt à
recevoir au biais des mairies toussaint
mais fait et dont on a besoin encore de
votre aide pour la recherche tout ça
comme le disait non loin donc nous
enfants attend d'eux comme chaque année
un petit peu eh ben
la collecte pour aller où au plus près
de l'a27 de ce et norman a dit il on m'a
dit sachant qu'en plus le généthon cette
année fête ses 30 ans on l'aura bien
compris c'est l'espoir qui finalement va
accompagner ce téléthon avec beaucoup
d'animations sont proposées c'est la fin
de ce sept huit sociétés merci à tous
les trois d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bon merci beaucoup pour donner pour sa
34ème téléthon on l'a bien entendu
durant cette émission il ya plusieurs
possibilités des collectes le digital et
quatre chiffres
les fameux 36 37 pour connaître les
animations à venir dans votre commune
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
internet de chaque ville cette émission
est quant à elle à revoir sur notre site
internet et sur notre application mobile
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
[Musique]